JOINS US FOR A POSTDEBATE RECAP.
FIRST IT'S FAIR TO SAY A
BRAND-NEW DEMOCRATIC FIELD.
FOR THE BETTER PART OF A YEAR,
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
DOMINATED THE POLLS AND THE
OTHER CANDIDATES IN THE RACE
ATTACKED HIM FROM THE LEFT WHICH
IS WEIRD TO SEE.
BIDEN STILL BELIEVED IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
INTERNATIONAL BORDERS AND HE
OPPOSED FORCED BUSING ALONG WITH
VIRTUALLY EVERY OTHER AMERICAN,
SO HE WAS AUGUST AND ONE OF
THOSE RIGHT WING EXTREMIST FROM
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WERE TELLING
YOU ON THE DEBATE STAGE.
IT WAS BIZARRE.
THANKFULLY THAT LINE OF ATTACK
IS OVER BECAUSE JOE BIDEN'S
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN ITSELF IS
IN EFFECT OVER.
NOBODY THINKS BIDEN IS GOING TO
BE THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE.
ELIZABETH WARREN IS THE FRONT
RUNNER NOW.
THAT'S NOT CONTESTED.
THE RACE IS HERS TO LOSE.
SO DURING LAST NIGHTS DEBATE,
ARRIVES ON THE STAGE DECIDED TO
HELP HER DO JUST THAT.
LOSE.
WATCH.
>> YOUR SIGNATURE, SENATOR, IS
TO HAVE A PLAN FOR EVERYTHING.
EXCEPT THIS.
>> AT LEAST BERNIE'S BEING
HONEST IN SAYING HOW HE'S GOING
TO PAY FOR THIS AND THAT TAXES
ARE GOING TO GO UP AND I'M
SORRY, ELIZABETH, BUT YOU HAVE
NOT SAID THAT.
>> I'M GOING TO SAY SOMETHING'S
PROBABLY GOING TO OFFEND SOME
PEOPLE HERE BUT I'M THE OTHER
ONE ON THE STAGE THAT'S GOTTEN
ANYTHING REALLY BIG DOWN.
>> I APPRECIATE ELIZABETH'S WORK
BUT AGAIN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
A PLAN AND A PIPE DREAM IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU CAN GET DONE.
>> I WENT ON THE FLOOR AND GOT
YOU VOTES.
I GOT VOTES FOR THAT BILL.
I CONVINCE PEOPLE TO VOTE FOR
IT.
SPEAK I WANT TO GIVE A REALITY
CHECK
HERE TO ELIZABETH BECAUSE
NO ONE ON THE STAGE WANTS TO
PROTECT BILLIONAIRES, NOT EVEN
THE BILLIONAIRE WANTS TO PROTECT
BILLIONAIRES.
>> SOMETIMES I THINK
SENATOR WARREN IS MORE FOCUSED
ON BEING PUNITIVE OR PITTING A
PART OF THE COUNTRY AGAINST EACH
OTHER.
>> Tucker: SHE IS PUNITIVE?
WHEN BETO O'ROURKE, MR. ARMED
FEDERAL AGENTS COMING TO YOUR
HOUSE CALLS YOU UP FOR DIVISIVE
ATTACKS, IT'S TIME TO PAY
ATTENTION.
IN FACT HE MAKES A FAIR POINT.
THE MAIN REASON WARREN HAS
SURPASSED BERNIE SANDERS IN THE
HEARTS OF PRIMARY VOTERS DESPITE
CLOSE ACADEMIC PROGRAMS IS THAT
SHE'S THE ONE FAR MORE WILLING
TO DISSENT INTO THE FILTH OF
IDENTITY POLITICS.
BERNIE IS AN IDEOLOGUE.
THERE ARE SOME THINGS HE JUST
WON'T SAY.
ELIZABETH WARREN WILL SAY
ANYTHING.
MINUTES AGO SHE TWEETED THIS
"EVERY PERSON DESERVES TO BE
TREATED WITH DIGNITY AND RESPECT
AND THAT STARTS WITH USING
CORRECT PRONOUNS.
I'M ELIZABETH.
MY PRONOUNS ARE SHE, HER, HERS."
IN CASE YOU'RE WONDERING, IN
CASE THERE WAS ANY QUESTIONS AT
ALL.
THAT KIND OF POSTURING IS
CENTRAL TO ELIZABETH WARREN'S
CAMPAIGN.
SHE'S HAPPY TO TELL YOU AND
OFTEN DOES THAT YOU'RE WORTHLESS
OR YOU'RE WITH MORE FACE ON HOW
YOU WERE BORN.
UNFORTUNATELY THAT WORKS RIGHT
NOW.
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
ONE THING A SYLLABUS TRICKLES
WITH WANTING IS NOT WILLING TO
SAY IS HOW MUCH OR SINGLE-PARENT
GOVERNMENT HEALTH CARE WILL COS
COST.
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS, NOBODY
DISPUTES THAT.
AS A MATHEMATICAL MATTER,
THERE'S NO WAY TO RAISE THAT
KIND OF MONEY WITHOUT HIKING
TAXES ON THE MIDDLE CLASS.
SIMPLE ARITHMETIC.
AND YET FOR SOME REASON, WARREN
REFUSES TO ADMIT IT.
WATCH.
>> YOU HAVE NOT SPECIFIED HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO PAY FOR THE MOST
EXPENSIVE PLAN, MEDICARE FOR
ALL.
WHERE WILL YOU RAISE TAXES ON
THE MIDDLE CLASS TO PAY FOR IT,Y
THE MIDDLE CLASS TO PAY FOR IT,S
OR NO?
>> I'VE MADE CLEAR WHAT MY
PRINCIPLES ARE.
THAT IS COST WILL GO UP FOR THE
WEALTHY AND FOR BIG CORPORATION
CORPORATIONS.
AND FOR HARDWORKING MIDDLE-CLASS
FAMILIES, COSTS WILL GO DOWN.
>> MAYOR BUTTIGIEG, YOU SAY
SENATOR WARREN HAS BEEN
"EVASIVE" ABOUT SHE'S GOOD TO
PAY FOR MEDICARE FOR ALL.
WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE.
>> WE HEARD IT TONIGHT.
A "YES" OR "NO" QUESTION THAT
DIDN'T GET A "YES" OR "NO"
ANSWER.
>> Tucker: SAVE THE DAY.
THERE ARE A LOT OF MOMENTS AND
DEBATES THAT SEEM LIKE A HUGE
DEAL AT THE TIME.
EVERYONE IS YAPPING ABOUT THEM
BUT IN THE END, TURNED OUT TO
BECOME FULLY MEANINGLESS.
THIS IS NOT ONE OF THOSE MOMENT
MOMENTS.
HEALTH CARE IS ALWAYS AT THE TOP
OF VOTERS' CONCERNS AND SORT
TAXES FOR THAT MATTER.
ELIZABETH WARREN CAN'T EVEN
EXPLAIN HER OWN SIGNATURE PLAN
TO REARRANGE THE ENTIRE AMERICAN
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM, SHE CAN'T
WIN.
EVEN A POSTDEBATE MSNBC PANEL
ACKNOWLEDGED AS MUCH.
>> I THOUGHT SHE SEEMED A LITTLE
PETULANT WHEN SHE WAS BEING
CHALLENGED.
>> A LITTLE?
>> A LITTLE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> AS BERNIE SANDERS SAYS, SHE
JUST WON'T GO THERE AND SHE WAS
PUMMELED FOR IT.
>> THEY ATTACKED HER AND SHE WAS
UNCOMFORTABLE.
SHE DID NOT HANDLE IT VERY WELL.
>> Tucker: ISN'T REALLY THAT
BAD FOR ELIZABETH ONE LAST
NIGHT?
WE'LL SEE.
SHE DEFTLY GOT BETTER TREATMENT
THAN JOE BIDEN I GOT.
JOURNALIST DON'T LIKE JOE BIDEN.
BIDEN HAS ZERO ALLIES IN
AMERICA'S WOKE NEWSROOMS.
WARREN HAS PLENTY OF ALLIES
PRETENDING TO BE JOURNALISTS.
THIS MORNING, NYU JOURNALISM
PROFESSOR, JAY ROSEN, A GUY
WHOSE NAME OFTEN POPS UP DESPITE
NO TALENT WHATSOEVER, DEMAND OF
THE REPORTED STOP ASKING
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ABOUT
WARREN'S POLICIES.
AGAIN, A JOURNALISM PROFESSOR
TELLING YOU NOT TO ASK
QUESTIONS.
"THE MAKE ELIZABETH WARREN SAY
SHE WOULD RAISE TAXES ON THE NEW
CLASS QUESTION SHOULD BE
INCREDIBLY COLOR FOR THE
JOURNALIST TO KEEP ASKING."
AMAZINGLY MARGARET SULLIVAN OF
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AGREED
WITH THAT.
SHE WROTE "JOURNALISTS ARE
KINDLY DOING PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
WORK FOR HIM WHEN THEY INSIST ON
TRYING TO PIN DOWN
SENATOR ELIZABETH WARREN WARREN
DECLARE SHE WOULD RAISE TAXES TO
DECLARE SHE WOULD RAISE TAXES TF
DECLARE SHE WOULD RAISE TAXES TN
DECLARE SHE WOULD RAISE TAXES TD
MEDICARE FOR ALL."
IT IS LEGITIMATE TO DIG INTO THE
COST BUT NOT IN A WAY THAT
CREATES A NICE G.O.P. CAMPAIGN
AD."
DID YOU LISTEN TO THAT?
TWO JOURNALIST TELLING YOU IF
THE ANSWER HURTS DEMOCRATS,
DON'T ASK THE QUESTION.
DON'T TELL YOUR READERS OR
VIEWERS WHAT THE TRUTH IS IF IT
INCREASES THE CHANCES THAT
DONALD TRUMP COULD GET
REELECTED.
IS THAT JOURNALISM?
NO.
IT IS PURE PROPAGANDA.
IT IS THE DEFINITION OF